bored hi I'm Josh I work at slack I'm
head of data engineering over there I
used to work at Cloudera I used to work
at Google used to work at some other
places I wrote a popular tweet about
data scientists once and I don't want to
really talk about it anymore cuz it's
been retweeted like 10,000 times and
it's kind of exhausting and I only own
the one hat which sadly I forgot today
so in my career among Google and cloud
era and slack I have done a lot of data
engineering and I have done a lot of
data science I've been on both sides of
this fence and so that was I guess the
reason why I was asked to talk about
bridging the gap between the two and so
I honestly I struggled with this topic
it's it's hard I work at slack now I
have a real job when I was a cloud era I
like my job was pretty much to give
presentations and so I was got really
good at giving presentations but I
eventually kind of stopped talking about
new things and so now I'm talking about
something new and I'm trying to figure
out what exactly to say about it
and I'll be honest with you I had kind
of a rough week with my data and data
analytics team at slack so my first
question is why should we bother
bridging the gap between data science
and data engineering like do we actually
need to do this is this actually worth
doing I'm actually I'm asking honestly
right now I guess like seriously like
yeah do we yeah kinda I don't know like
why bother like data I mean for me it's
like a data engineering data sciences or
these are two very sexy very attractive
jobs but we spend most of our time kind
of in couples therapy I guess it's like
working on our relationship stuff and I
wonder why that is because things start
out like so well if you if you ever get
the chance or if you personally had the
experience of ever being like the very
first data science data analytics data
engineering person at a company and
you're like by yourself it's like those
people are so sad and so unhappy like
they really are they like really the
first like data engineering person they
want nothing more than like a data
analyst person to come along and like
write sequel queries and dashboards so
they don't have to anymore
and the first like data science person
if they have
going to be first all they really want
is like an engineer who will just like
get them data and provide them with data
they need that they they can't get
themselves so like we sort of long for
each other and then you know like if
your company succeeds and like you
actually managed to hire that first data
engineer or that first data scientist is
sort of a compliment things are usually
like okay for a little while but where I
find like the problems sort of the
source of the problems between data
Stata science data analytics and data
engineering really come down to the fact
that we we fundamentally want different
things and you can actually see that if
you look at the titles of the
presentations of the of the like
different tracks today so I did this
thing I did a very advanced analysis
called word count on the the titles of
the talks and the most sort of
frequently used words in the data
science track besides you know obviously
data right data's used everywhere were
systems and learning systems of learning
and most of the talks focus on like
machine learning or some kind of system
for doing recommendations or something
like that and the most popular word by
far in the data engineering talks is is
scale that's that's really we're sort of
talking about different things like data
scientists want the ability to like
explore datasets discover insights
discover sort of new information new
metrics quickly get those values get
those get that information into
production into a position where it can
be used to help people make better
decisions they want to do kind of fancy
cool advanced analytics fancy cool
machine learning impress other data
scientists all that kind of good stuff
data engineers on the other hand really
want efficiency they want reliability
they want high throughput they want low
latency and more than anything what they
want is scale because nothing impresses
other data engineers quite like scale
and these sort of two wishes these two
goals aren't like necessarily perfectly
compatible with one another and that's
sort of where the divergence excuse me
between us starts to happen so what sort
of seems to happen over time as data
engineering data science teams grow is
something that I call the infinite loop
of sadness and I've coined this term I
think I'm in a trade market actually
this is this is the infinite loop of
sadness let's kind of walk around the
infinite loop
so let's start with the business all
right
the business makes unreasonable and
ill-informed requests of the data
science team for basically information
and answers to questions that are either
like completely irrelevant or not
possible using the data they have or
methodologically inappropriate it's
something like that right basically the
business makes ridiculous requests of
the data science team the data science
team in turn makes ridiculous requests
of the data engineering team like they
want to do everything in I don't know
probably Python or something like that
using GPUs and all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
like that
the data engineering team in turn makes
ridiculous requests of the operations
team to run stream processing engines
that barely work they can't be monitored
all that kind of good stuff and the ops
team basically then goes to the business
and says holy crap we need a lot more
money to support all of the stuff that
we're doing right now and of course like
things flow the other way to write the
ops the data engineering team feels that
the ops team puts onerous constraints on
like what the data engineering team can
do the data science team feels that the
data engineering it's like
infrastructure is very limited and not
flexible enough for what they need and
the business feels that the data science
team can't answer any questions that
they want and the business is like well
maybe we should just fire all these ops
people and outsource them to someone
else so everyone everyone in this sort
of circle is constantly trying to
outsource the other person they depend
on roughly speaking this is this is the
world most of us inhabit like let's be
honest right this this is the way this
works it's very sad hence the infinite
loop of sadness so as a result we're
sort of like alone together there's
there's a very strong temptation I think
in data science and engineering to sort
of go off into our own little worlds
where we don't really have to kind of
deal with the other person so much so
you have like the data engineering team
off building you know crazy stream
processing engines and sort of streaming
data flows to power production systems
because they don't really need the data
scientist to do that like there's
requirements and they're well-defined
and the latency and all that kind of
stuff is a very clean good engineering
problem and so they didn't engineers go
off and do that
and the data scientists go off and they
build their own kind of like defect you
know a de facto sketchy crappy data
engineering infrastructure so that they
can do things the way they want to do
them so lots of you know like
downloading massive datasets onto their
desktop and loading them up in tableau
or R or whatever and all this kind of
stuff so we're like we're alone together
basically we're not really like working
that well together and this is very very
sad and so I think I'd like to sort of
fix that and the way we're gonna fix
that is sort of starting with first
principles the first principle of
building any data infrastructure is that
you only need to understand and
appreciate two things apache Kafka and
and Franz Kafka and the Apache Kafka
part I think should be obvious to
everyone by far like Kafka is like
oxygen you don't I mean like saying you
use Kafka is like saying used Linux it's
like the least interesting statement in
San Francisco but the the Franz Kafka
part is actually I think interesting and
important and I'm gonna turn I'm gonna
turn to David Foster Wallace and he
wrote this great essay about sort of
Kafka's sense of humor in this book if
you were to read it like in the essay
somewhere but it's an about called
consider the lobster um and he sort of
gives this whole paragraph which I'm not
gonna read to you because I don't have
that much time about sort of Kafka sense
of humor but like the idea is the
central joke in Kafka's writing is that
the horrific struggle to establish a
human self results in a self whose
humanity is inseparable from that
horrific struggle you want to envision
envision readers coming up and pounding
on some like imagine imagine Kafka's art
as a kind of door and envision readers
coming up and pounding on this door
pounding and pounding not just wanting
admission but needing it we don't know
what it is but we can feel at this total
desperation to enter pounding and
pushing and kicking etc etc and finally
the door opens and it opens outward and
we were inside of what we wanted the
whole time and that's that's comedy
obviously in a very sort of bleak well
Kafkaesque sense I suppose but the
reality is the struggle to build data
infrastructure results in a data
infrastructure that is inseparable from
that horrific struggle roughly speaking
and that's that's kind of a thing data
engineers and data scientists we need
each other
the really really good engineering
problems right now exist in basically
enabling the data scientists to do the
things they want to do and the data
scientists do not get the world they
really want to inhabit unless they work
with the data engineers in order to
create it and so we need to repair this
relationship and the way to start
repairing it is first and foremost to
start with the infinite loop of sadness
and sort of change our perspective and
think of it as the infinite loop of
empathy because we're roughly speaking
data science and data engineering have
similar relationships in the infinite
loop right the way the data science
feels about data engineering is the way
the data engineering feels about ops
right so if you're a data engineer and
you're like getting this sort of
ridiculous incoming request from the
data science team imagine that it's like
the sort of same kind of request you're
making of the ops team that seems
completely reasonable to you and you
don't understand why you can't just go
do it roughly speaking and vice-versa
when the like data engineering team
pushes back on the data science team
that's sort of like the data science
team pushing back on the business to say
hey that's a terrible idea you shouldn't
do that you should do things this way
because it'll actually be like
meaningful and accurate and have
confidence intervals and all that kind
of good stuff so we start with empathy
and it the empathy sort of flows from
the fact that we sort of we're sort of
in this together right we have we have
similar relationships with each other
that we have with other teams and that
should help us understand what it's like
to work with the other person um one of
the things that's really honestly most
helpful for bringing data science and
data engineering together is machine
learning
machine learning is a great place for
everyone to collaborate because machine
learning is a situation where everyone's
goals are fundamentally aligned we want
meaningful metrics we want to optimize
them we want to deploy machine learning
models into production that are reliable
that are instrumented that are the ops
team is happy with we get kind of
everybody pushing in the same direction
at the same time and so if you work at a
company where machine learning is a
critical part of what you do and you're
on sort of the machine learning focused
part of the team that is that is an
opportunity to create a great
relationship between data science and
data engineering however not everybody
does or works at companies that need
mission
learning or do much machine learning or
anything like that and so while that's
like a good situation to be in it's not
going to solve the problem sort of that
the Delta between data science and data
engineering for everybody but I think
there's something that that the can and
it's it's really ETL I just I love this
comic strip and you all should read it
and appreciate it cuz it's just so dark
and twisted everybody ETLs
everybody TLS no matter who you are no
matter where you are everyone does ETL
extract transform and load occasionally
I know I don't need to say that in this
room but like sometimes I talked to like
software engineers at slack and I say
ETL and they have no idea what I'm
talking about which is just bizarre to
me but whatever so yeah everyone needs
to you know read in data apply
transforms to it and write it out
someplace else that's pretty much the
definition of software engineering and
there's a couple of different patterns
I've seen for doing ETL that I've sort
of come across and working with people
from Google and from Facebook and from
Twitter and all these kind of things and
the first pattern I see is is what I
call sequel centric ETL and this is for
me in many ways a sort of very data
science data analytics oriented
perspective on ETL so all of the ETL in
these systems is a bunch of sequel
queries as much of hive queries they are
in stare sort of like managed in a
somewhat opaque way by an ETL workflow
engine like airflow or Luigi or pinball
like one of these kinds of systems and
it's very much like all about sequel and
this is great for day analysts because
it's very easy for them to kind of
understand things and like see sort of
how pipelines get defined it's very easy
for them to extend them it's reasonably
easy for them to extend these pipelines
and add them add new metrics and have
them do new things um but in my opinion
this is not really like a great
environment for data engineers because
data is yours tenants been a lot of
their time you know trying to fix like
very broken and inefficient sequel
pipelines or writing you know UDF's in
Java using hives sort of horrible object
inspector kind of unbelievable nightmare
thing so this is I think of sequel
central ETL is fundamentally an
analytics centric ETL it's a world that
primarily benefits analysts at the
expense of data engineers and that's
that makes me sad and then there's sort
of option two which is JVM centric ETL a
JVM centric ETL is all of the the real
ETL we do is done in Java and or Scala
or something like that and it's like
very sort of elegant and highly highly
functional and relatively difficult to
understand unless you have a degree in
abstract algebra but is like very
reliable and very efficient and not
necessarily sort of it as accessible to
data analysts in order to be able to go
play and sort of explore and try out new
metrics and make modifications to these
pipelines without involving a data
engineer and some non-trivial sense and
if you happen to be a dana engineer who
really really likes writing scala this
may be like a perfectly acceptable happy
world for you but i don't think it's a
great environment for most data analysts
i don't think it really meets their
needs i don't think it really makes them
kind of happy so what I'm interested in
is sort of a third way and like most
third ways it's gonna be something that
makes everyone kind of unhappy and the
third way is what I've been working on
right now at slack and I'm gonna sort of
talk about I want to talk a little bit
about like how I got here like how I
sort of arrived it like thinking about
the problem in this way based on the
fact that I mean fundamentally if I have
empathy for data analysts and I have
empathy for data of data engineers I
really want everybody to be not happy
but at least like the same level of
unhappy I guess is probably the best I
can hope for I can't really make
everyone happy but I can make everyone
equally unhappy because that makes it
like Pareto style unhappiness roughly
speaking I don't know why that's funny
like I'm perfectly serious and that's
that's kind of what I set out to do or
at least what I what I'm trying to do
right now and I think most of my team
thinks I'm kind of crazy and I suspect a
large number of you will think I'm kind
of crazy too but such as life alright
let's talk about this a few different
trends a few different things going on
right now
that are influencing sort of the way I'm
thinking about ETL the way I'm thinking
about building pipelines first and
foremost is the rise of spark spark is
so I love this this is the Standard Oil
comic strip from like back in the Gilded
Age of the 1880s or 1890s whatever spark
is like standard oil if data is the new
oil spark is the new standard oil it has
tentacles everywhere there's literally
no sort of part of the data stack that
spark does not touch in some way and if
I invented a new data processing
framework tomorrow that took advantage
of I don't know GPUs that were plugged
into InfiniBand connections across a
cluster the next day spark would have an
implementation that would do effectively
the same thing so yeah spark is really
because of sort of its tentacles because
it touches so many different things
because of its sequel integration
because of its streaming integration
because of its memory sort of centric
computing model spark really sort of
opens up some new and very very
interesting possibilities for us that
we're not true before in this sort of
very MapReduce or sequel centric world
that we've been inhabiting for quite
some time I mean especially if the scale
of like say slack which is not even
remotely like big data like we log like
a few billion events a day spark can be
really really really interesting for
doing sort of data processing in a sort
of new way and I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about that in a second
that said the second kind of theme that
that's plaguing me right now is we have
too many stream processing engines so I
think I just got a sample here I didn't
even include all of them I left out gear
pump so apologies to gear pump but spark
streaming samsa kafka streams storm
flanked there probably was another one
invented while I was just standing here
talking we have lots and lots and lots
of stream processing engines and you
know if you're if you're in data
engineering now you know like at Google
there was this joke that there were two
ways to do to solve any problem the way
that was deprecated and the way that
doesn't work yet and that's that's kind
of the nature of data engineering right
now batch processing is deprecated but
stream processing really doesn't work
yet that's like the situation we find
ourselves in but everything
is going towards streaming if you know
for sure 100% what's streaming what
stream processing engine you're gonna be
using like 12 to 24 months from right
right now I'm gonna say you're either an
idiot or you're like full of [ __ ] like
basically like you know and no one has
any idea what the stream processing
engine of like the near future is going
to be there's too many of these things
they all have pros they all have cons
devil you know W don't all that kind of
get stuff but there's lots and lots of
options here and it's not really clear
to me like what is going to win or if
some new fundamental paradigm is going
to emerge tomorrow that makes all this
stream processing stuff suddenly makes
sense to everyone so the way that's
deprecated and the way that doesn't work
yet that said just because we have lots
and lots and lots of different stream
processing engines to choose from the
design patterns around streaming or
actually kind of reasonably well
understood there's things like summing
bird right so something ever from
Twitter is essentially a pattern like
library for doing unified stream batch
data processing there was a great blog
post on O'Reilly recently by a guy used
to work with a cloud era named Joe
Echevarria where he talked about like
creating configuration languages to
handle most of the sort of very common
patterns that you can encounter when
you're doing a stream processing so like
all the stream processing right now is
essentially flat map followed by
aggregations with an occasional sort of
left join style lookup into some other
key value store like that's sort of the
dominant pattern by far and so even
though there's all this complexity and
all this richness around the various
stream engines the stream processing
models the actual sort of core patterns
we use day-to-day most commonly are
actually pretty well understood we have
a pretty good sense of these things at
the moment and that's an interesting
situation that's interesting opportunity
um finally I think I think the fact that
we have so much great data
infrastructure now so many great data
engineering tools so many like ways of
handling scale and all this kind of good
stuff means that we can we can finally
sort of focus on the real problem which
is which is change this changes
everyone's problem how do we evolve
these systems how do we like define new
metrics how do we restore
sure the pipelines how do we move things
from a batch world to a stream
processing world fundamentally how do we
handle change this is this is the real
problem this is the problem we need to
solve much more so in my opinion than
scale at the moment
the real problem is change so we need to
solve the real problem so the approach
that we've been playing around with
right now I'll take some inspiration
from deep learning there's a couple of
different sort of main mainstream deep
learning libraries there's tensorflow
there's Theon oh there's torch and they
all actually sort of employ a very
similar paradigm there's a sort of
low-level systems language C C++
whatever that's optimized for very
intensive compute processing and then
there is a high-level scripting language
that allows you to configure the
low-level systems language and do
whatever kind of high-level bookkeeping
scripting tasks you need to do right so
it's either Lua or Python or whatever
sort of on top of a low level C++ engine
right this this is a fairly common
pattern and I think that this is roughly
the right pattern for doing ETL and
doing data processing right now and I
realized this is gonna be controversial
and I want to kind of head off the first
the first sort of objection to this
which is a high level scripting language
like Python or JavaScript is not
statically typed and static typing is
really in many ways like the sort of
universal thing in data engineering
right now sequel is fundamentally a
statically typed language Scala all that
kind of stuff the way we do typing I
wrote a Java library called Apache
crunch which was like even more
statically typed and scalding it was
like even cryo was like not sufficient
for me from a typing perspective so for
a long long time I've been a major
advocate of static typing for data
pipelines just because there's nothing
worse than writing an enormous pipeline
having it run for hours and then like
failing at the last possible second
because of a you know type checking
problem that you could have caught at
the very start of the pipeline right
everyone sort of nods because everyone's
had this painful experience at some
point yes okay good job um
but what's interesting to me right now
is I think a couple of things have
changed have basically lowered the cost
of rerunning things to the point where
I'm actually much more interested in
Python and JavaScript for writing
pipelines as sort of not just
configuring them but writing them as
well one is sort of the introduction of
spark and the fact that I can really
quickly load up a dataset into memory
cache it there apply some data
processing logic to it have it fail
reload my JavaScript or Python and run
it again and run it again and run it
again like interactively so I mean it's
it's sort of getting to the point where
like working with big data is becoming
more and more like you know doing some
ETL or processing on like a CSV file you
happen have on your machine it's
becoming sort of closer to that and as
we move closer and closer to that the
cost of static type checking sort of you
know errors goes down significantly and
as a result of that we can sort of
embrace some of the flexibility and
advantages we get from the sort of non
non statically typed dynamically typed
languages the other thing is that with
with languages with sort of with the
evolution of Python 3 and with libraries
like flow for JavaScript evolutionary
sort of static typing like sort of
slowly slowly to evolving type systems
are becoming kind of a thing in the
Python and the and the JavaScript
communities and this is really good news
we can kind of like type things as they
make sense add typing in places just
sort of as we see fit while still having
the flexibility to just sort of hack
interactively on data when we want to so
this is the sort of like the combination
these things the in-memory processing
was spark and this sort of slowly
evolving static typing or you know not
quite static typing make using scripting
languages a much more practical option
in my opinion than we've ever really had
before so I've been working on creating
a system based on these principles based
on the principle of spark sort of
in-memory computation based on the
principle that I don't know what stream
processing engine I'm going to use I'll
probably choose one I'll probably be
unhappy with it will probably choose
another one right and the fact that
these sort of scripting languages are
becoming interesting and possible for
him
a lot of the fairly like boilerplate
easy parts of data processing that don't
necessarily need a full-on systems
language so in choosing between sort of
Python and JavaScript I ended up going
with JavaScript for a couple of
different reasons
and the main one is that I work at slack
and if you guys don't know the origin
myth of slack um slack was originally a
game called glitch and actually if you
still if you go to a 404 on if you find
a 404 on slack comm this is the page you
get um glitch was this like incredibly
cool game they had developed was sort of
like ridiculously open-ended but
unfortunately didn't succeed and
essentially they the company took the
very last of their VC money and used it
to launch slack which was an internal
tool they had developed for themselves
in the course of creating the game but
the glitch was a game and the game
engine itself was written in Java but
the level designer was all in JavaScript
it was all in like rhino and national
art and that kind of stuff right so it
so happened that working at slack with a
bunch of people who used to work on
glitch there's a tremendous amount of
in-house expertise around rhino and
national Oran and kind of like what
they're good for and how to use them and
stuff like that that I was able to
leverage in creating some of the stuff
I've been working on for for ETL
workflows and this is roughly what I've
come up with so again keeping in mind
the sort of spirit of deep learning
there's there's a mixture of
configuration stuff and just sort of
full-on flexible programming stuff but
the way this model works is you create a
javascript file that imports some sort
of core libraries of the framework and
one of the things you can do I'm kind of
obviously is define output tables that
this ETL script is going to run that's
going to generate so you basically give
a table a name you specify a set of
fields and you say that hey aggregation
engine processing engine I want you to
group by these fields that will come in
in some record and sum and aggregate
these other fields and and you can
define multiple tables in a single
script and we will do all of the kind of
table processing at the same time over
sort of the same input data set so
imagine load the data set in memory if
they if you find a bunch of different
tables a bunch of different agric
you're going to do and they're all going
to process exactly the same data your
best bet in spark is to just like load
the data they need into memory cache it
and then do the processing over those
tables all at once much more efficiently
than running a bunch of separate kind of
individual jobs in order to do whatever
grens you need to do so the slack our
logs our thrift logs are called slogs
our client logs are called clogs our job
key loggers are called jogs it kind of
it started and just kind of got out of
hand you guys know that goes so the
reference there just slogs is sort of
our thrift based our thrift based logs
and process daily actives is a function
defined in the JavaScript file which
takes in a slog extracts information
from it basically doing essentially a
flat map to emit records to whatever
downstream tables you have so whatever
kind of common logic for computing daily
active users or any other kind of thing
you want to do can be defined here in
one place it can be tested all that sort
of good stuff all this becomes possible
and the really nice thing about this is
it sort of eliminates in many ways the
problem of moving from a DSL into sort
of a low-level systems language there's
like hive and pig and all kinda stuff
are great until you have to write a UDF
and the reason languages like scalding
came along we're because you could
basically write the UDF at the same time
you were doing the pipeline and you
didn't have to like change environments
and I don't want to like lose that
feature that functionality of scalding I
just want to enable people to do it in
an environment where they don't
necessarily have to learn Scala for
analysts and stuff like that everyone
knows JavaScript everyone hates
JavaScript it's totally fine no big deal
but it is it is like lingua franca like
everyone knows JavaScript no matter what
you do you can do some JavaScript so mmm
no need to write UDF's no need to pop
down into Java whenever you need some
custom extensions just write the code
you need but just because we're doing
scripting doesn't mean we can that's we
necessarily have to give up sequel so I
have come to mainly appreciate and be
occasionally annoyed by spark sequel and
it's
integration with hive the fact that I
can like programmatically basically look
at the output tables that get generated
from one of these JavaScript things and
say okay the tables coming back with
these fields let me compare that to the
schema of the hive table I want to write
to and make modifications to the hive
schema in order to support the new data
on writing like being able to do
programmatic DDL in preparation for like
actually inserting loading new datasets
is very very cool and makes my life like
tremendously better also sort of like
being able to specify these dependencies
between jobs is basically a way sort of
expressing to whatever system is running
all this ETL what data should be left in
memory what data should be cached and
what data what order of operations
things should be done in because we have
essentially all of this structured
metadata around what tables are needed
when how they need to be joined all that
kind of good stuff that we can use to
optimize the overall flow of our ETL
pipelines and this is very nice compared
to say like air flow or Luigi or
whatever we're essentially the hive
query is like basically opaque to me and
I can't necessarily tell inside of the
query what all tables like it would be
really really useful if they were like
cached in memory right now but doing all
this stuff this way in JavaScript
exposes all this information in a
structured way to spark and so we can
decide okay we're gonna do this this and
this processing then we're gonna cash
this result in memory do these joins and
then finally write everything out and we
can have a lot of opportunities to
optimize not just an individual job or
an individual query but the entire
workflow as it evolves over time alright
so this is a brave new world right now
right this this is roughly like sort of
the crazy ideas that we are working on
at slack as a different way of doing
data engineering a way of doing data
engineering where analysts can define
pipelines and make modifications to them
and sort of automate a lot of the tedium
of doing things a world in which
everyone can interactively load data up
into memory try out scripts try out new
ideas play with the results see if
they're a fit
if they are quickly move them into
production pipelines in the world where
engineers data engineers in particular
are sort of allowed to work on maybe
like one of the most interesting truly
interesting resource management data
engineering problems of our time which
is basically taking the sort of
arbitrary dag of queries and jobs and
all destruction information and finding
a way to optimize it and finding a way
to like process it all very very
efficiently this is a much more
satisfying problem for me than the
writing ETF's
or even defining like a type theoretic
library in Scala like this is this is
the real stuff for me this is what I'm
excited about right now and yeah I think
that's pretty much it thank you all very
very much
I wouldn't we know we're hiring so
obviously
oh I think I only ended up talking for
like half an hour so sorry about that
but I'm happy to take questions on this
stuff or literally anything else anyone
might want to ask me about do we have
like you do have a microphone or
something or what are we doing for this
is this the thing there's that you this
nice woman back here has a microphone
and saw the guy in the blue shirt back
there had a question don't walk too
slowly Pete we need to kill some time I
didn't talk long enough check check so
as a data engineer how many languages
should I know and what order should I
learn them and how good should I be at
them man that is a phenomenally good
question I love that question
JavaScript exactly it's all JavaScript
from here on out you're done you're
welcome America yeah I get like a bunch
of maple bacon scones thrown at me up
your own stage no I seriously want to
answer that question
so yeah you need to learn all of them
it's like seriously like this side
answer you need to learn all of them at
and I just like I mean it's lack our
data engineering team is five people and
we have like analysts I guess like seven
analysts or seven let me just like walk
through the set of programming languages
that I use on a weekly basis all right
so I write JavaScript obviously right
but I write not only like you know back
in Rhino style JavaScript I write
front-end JavaScript as well because I
work on the client-side libraries we use
really instrumenting and capturing
events right so roll out rolled our own
segments effectively speaking with
apologies to the segment IO people who
were nice enough to sponsor this
conference and send me cookies and other
gifts and stuff like that anyway
PHP because the web application at slack
is written in PHP it's like just sort of
a litany of terrible programming
languages more or less I mean the core
application is written in PHP PHP as we
all know is like a web app you know
development framework that kind of got
out of hand and turned into a
programming language so I know PHP our
ETL engine is written in go because why
the [ __ ] not
our ETL configuration library that was
written in Python because the analysts
know Python and it's
fairly easy to express these
dependencies in Python Java because
there are high of sir days and UDF's and
all that kind of stuff
Scala because there's scallop pipelines
as well they're scalding jobs they're
spark jobs all this kind of systems
infrastructure for the JavaScript stuff
I'm talking about all Scala god I think
that's it that's enough right that's
enough programming languages for one
person to work within one week roughly
does everyone agree in terms of order of
operations say great question it kind of
depends on where you're coming in if you
are the like very first data engineer
and or organization you're probably like
your first job is probably to learn
JavaScript in sequel just to be like
perfectly honest with you it's it's kind
of a heartbreaker if you've been doing a
bunch of like Python to ipython
notebooks and you want to do machine
learning but really instrumentation is
like the first requirement by far
actually collecting the data in the
first place is the hard problem
javascript and sequel are both very very
easy to learn and will like totally get
you going and get you started if you
want to join a much larger data
engineering team and an existing company
I think at Facebook you probably gonna
want to learn Java if you're going to
Twitter you're probably gonna want to
learn Scala I don't know any other sort
of if you want to come to slack then I
mean just I mean I listed like six
languages just pick one and tell me
which one you want to learn first it's
totally fine yeah I mean I think it's
not for nothing like this I love this
aspect of data engineering I love the
fact that I get to would like switch
context and work with all these
different programming languages on a
fairly regular basis that is something I
enjoy I know a lot of people it's like
Haskell or nothing and I'm just not one
of those people so it's it's great for
me it's like one of the reasons I'm very
happy that I chose this career one of
actually maybe maybe the only reason I'm
happy that I chose its career to be
honest with you but I mean I love that
aspect of it alright long-winded answer
killed sometime awesome next question
right here is that okay it's like
literally right up front just gonna make
Pete run around it's super fun for me so
the JavaScript that you're working on
yeah there's any of it open source is
there like a live
yeah none of it is none of his
open-source and it's more or less kids
like I started working in it like a week
ago
you know enemy which is like one of the
reasons why it was hard to figure out
what to talk about today cuz I was like
do I really want to talk about this or
are they gonna throw maple bacon scones
at me like that kind of thing and even
like some of like the syntax stuff I
still haven't figured out like I still
up and figured out like what should a
side input look like in this world like
how do I like load how do I run a query
off of some table and cache some data in
JavaScript and make it available you
know figuring out like what the language
should look like and really more than
anything what what's the carrot what is
what is the carrot that gets the
analysts to give up sequel and hive in
favor of this how do I make this
compelling for them right I can't force
them to use it I can force my own team
to use it kind of they can also quit and
go somewhere else it's not like date
engineers or like you know no one wants
to hire them or something like that
they're actually all here right now
so high slack the engineering team hi
everybody how's it going so please don't
try to hire my team yeah I would love to
open source it at some point I really
would people are gonna hire them if you
make them all learn JavaScript yeah well
I mean like what does it like how do you
learn like I mean every I feel like
JavaScript just kind of know it right
it's just you just sort of like you just
sort of Intuit you look at JavaScript
really okay this looks stupid I can do
this I mean it's not you know kind of
serious I'm not taking any questions
from Eric Samer by the way that was part
of my contractual agreement not its
requirement required no questions hey
how you doing hey doing great good sorry
to keep it on JavaScript but to avoid
the horror of JavaScript
yeah look at typescript typescript I
have not looked at typescript I am
actually very much amenable to anything
aside from I guess I hear horrible
things about CoffeeScript like people
don't use CoffeeScript that's that
that's a bad thing I have some Facebook
people tell me to look at flow which is
like sort of a you know eventually type
kind like hack hack is the PHP is flows
the JavaScript roughly speaking is
typescript kind of like that is that the
same idea I would call it basically es6
with some extra goodies yeah
some people call it c-sharp envisioned
as Jay s okay I mean I like it's sort of
a grown to the room right I mean I think
I mean guys we're talking about writing
ETL pipelines in JavaScript the groaning
ship is kind of sailed already right
like anyway that sounds interesting I
will totally check it out yeah thank you
yes so question so the spark API is
great I think everyone agrees on that
yeah so so why do we need a JavaScript
DSL great point about it great question
a couple of reasons a couple of reasons
one spark API is great but you need to
actually like write spark fund it in
some fundamental sense and if you're
writing spark I sort of sadly lose in
some sense the opportunity to optimize
the overall execution flow so I like the
sort of like declarative aspect in some
sense of having some kind of
configuration language that shows a
declarative aspect of it which is like I
really just need this set of things to
happen somehow and then leave it to like
the system the data engineering system
to figure out in what order that sort of
set of things should happen spark is
great if you like no spark really well
and you know not to do like say group
bys and stuff like that if you know to
always do reduce by key if you know how
to tune it properly
all that kind of stuff I think spark is
great and I want to say that like it's
not like this is a replacement for
everything it's totally not there are
still very core data pipelines that will
be written like natively
in Scala in scalding and spark or
whatever when that makes sense what I'm
trying to do is provide a way for the
data analysts who don't necessarily know
Scala don't necessarily know that in on
AWS s3 you need to set the rack locality
to zero for the wait time for spark all
that kind of nonsense I don't really
want to have like for them to care the
other reason is while I like spark a lot
for batch processing I am honestly I
kind of personally not totally sold on
spark streaming as my stream processing
engine the garbage collection stuff just
seems really crappy and I like I'm very
ambivalent about a system where like I
have to restart the goddamn thing like
every 24 hours to deal with like out of
memory issues I am NOT I'm not savvy
enough to know
whether that is like an intrinsic
problem of the spark programming model
or whether that is something that is
fixable I don't think like rewriting the
whole engine from scratch and the 2.0
thing is the right solution to that
problem that kind of is [ __ ]
terrifying so I've heard good things
about flink I generally trust the Kafka
people and think they can do good stuff
and so just to be perfectly honest and
blunt I kind of want to keep my options
open when it comes to choosing a stream
processing engine and I really want the
logic the analysts define for creating
core metrics for saying this is a daily
active user this is someone who writes a
post I really want that core logic to be
like literally identical in my batch in
my stream processing systems I want it
for my batch systems for like internal a
be testing experimentation metrics all
that kind of good stuff and for the
stream processing engine which is gonna
be showing and metrics like two teams to
admin saying this is the number of daily
active users you've had slack has this
fair fair billing policy right where we
only bill you for people who actually
use slack in a certain way in a given
month and so that's stream processing
and that batch processing it has to be
identical it's like not not an option
for it not to be and so abstracting away
from the underlying execution engine
gives me some optimization opportunities
doesn't necessarily tie me into spark
streaming in a way that I'm just not
super comfortable with yet so
long-winded answer but that's that's
roughly like the philosophy behind it
let's do two more two more okay uh I saw
this guy in the blue shirt here but
where's where's Pete oh there he is okay
it's like a big thing here so sorry guy
blue shirt yeah right there hey Josh
great doc was it thank you what's good
it's really finished like so the jerks
recycled but that was like yeah that's
always true yeah so I if you serve
hinted at different parts of this slack
data engineering stack yeah but I was
wondering figure just walked through
like what exactly what does it look like
right now and like what's the future
vision for this yeah that's a great
question what it looks like right now is
probably closer to the sequel centric
kind of like data engineering world view
most of our ETL is so we use thrift logs
we also have some JSON logs and Apache
logs for kind of like random one-off
event sort of stuff
we ETL all that stuff primarily using
hive I'm into parquet we do the vast
majority of our interactive query via
presto we do some roll-ups on that data
and we stored it on my sequel database
for powering like dashboards and BOTS
and all that kind of stuff we do a
big-ass ridiculous replication job to
replicate our prodigal data which is
sharded all kinds of dozens of different
ways using a tool called scooper duper
which basically like spins up a copy of
slack and like just Hoover's data right
out of it um everything is s3 everything
is parquet um a little bit of scalding
for some things where like scalding was
a better fit a little bit of spark for
some things where spark was a better fit
that that kind of thing that's sort of
the world we inhabit at the moment yeah
I don't know like I said carrot stick
kind of situation I can't force the
analysts to give up hive and stuff like
that they want to use hive then we'll
just spin up more clusters and drive up
our ops budget accordingly and stuff
like that my other work my sort of
carrot for them the more than anything
is like I was just saying about having
the core metrics defined exactly the
same way in the batch world in the
streaming world if the core the true
metric of the defines our core logic is
defined in sequel and defined in hive
like it's gonna be like [ __ ]
impossible to keep it in sync with
whatever stream processing engine we end
up with even if underneath the covers
they're still processing fundamentally
the same logs data off of Kafka or
whatever so yeah that's that's a great
question I probably shoulda like threw
in a slide up into the talk earlier so
sorry thank you grass can that yeah I
gotcha
I was like so many questions I'm glad we
have office hours deep last question all
right hey Josh hey it's going in what's
going on yeah you know hanging out
giving a talk awesome so most of what
you've been talking about kind of like
looks more at the like analyst II like
sequel reporting layer yeah does
anything change in in your mind when
you're looking at like data product yeah
things that have to go into the apps
another another great question these are
all things that really should have
talked about in the talk but then again
people get to look really smart by
asking me these really interesting
questions so that is a little bit
further out of my mind but it is like
something I'm definitely keeping in mind
we
like so slack for instance has some of
our some of our services in production
our Java servers that are running like
national earn essentially to do like
scripted as esque aspects of some of our
processing and since we know how to
deploy that stuff into production we
never like we're comfortable running it
and comfortable monitoring it I am sort
of curious if I can convince our machine
learning team in New York to basically
build their machine learning algorithms
in Scala using all the great Scout stuff
Scala has available but do a lot of
their feature engineering in a sort of
scripting issue a on top of like thrift
records that are basically being
processed using this kind of DSL and
then feeding into the underlying model
fitting and scoring stuff underneath so
much so as part of like Josh wills
fantasy world where I could pick up a
bunch of features that I built you know
like the actual literal code that was
used to generate the features in the
offline batch process and drop it into a
server running in production for online
model surveying that is my my great
fantasy so yes I am thinking about that
no I am NOT tackling that problem quite
yet yeah awesome thanks Josh good thanks
everybody